(gentle music)
- [Allison] The US is lifting
it's travel restrictions
for people who are entering
from foreign countries.
Starting November 8th,
as long as they are fully vaccinated
and can prove it,
they can enter the US.
This affects both air and
land border travelers.
So here's what you need to
know about the new policy.
(gentle music)
During the pandemic,
there were travel bans imposed
by the Trump Administration,
and the new rules that
are going into effect
replace those banneds.
Starting November 8th,
foreign nationals will be
allowed to enter the US
if they're fully vaccinated
and can show proof of vaccination.
They also need to have
a negative COVID test
taken within three days
if they're traveling by air,
but that negative COVID
test is not necessary
if they're traveling by land.
(gentle music)
The acceptable vaccines
are ones that have been
authorized or approved
by the Food and Drug Administration,
or vaccines that have been
listed for emergency use
by the World Health Organization.
So that includes the Pfizer vaccine,
Moderna, Johnson & Johnson,
as well as AstraZeneca and China's
Sinopharm and Sinovac vaccines.
Russia's Sputnik V vaccine
has not been authorized
or approved by the FDA or WHO.
(gentle music)
There are limited exemptions to the rules.
So those include kids under 18,
certain vaccine clinical
trial participants,
and those with medical exemptions.
There are exceptions for people
who need to travel for emergency
or humanitarian reasons,
but these people need to get
a US Government issued letter
that verifies their urgent need to travel.
Now there are also exceptions for people
who are traveling on non-tourist visas
from countries with low
vaccine availability,
and those countries are
determined by the CDC.
(gentle music)
There are also changes for US citizens
and lawful permanent residents
for returning from abroad by air.
If you are fully vaccinated,
you'll need to show your
proof of vaccination
as well as a negative COVID test
that was taken within three days.
But if you are unvaccinated,
you will need to show
a negative COVID test
that was taken within one day.
(gentle music)
So kids who are under 18
are exempted from the
vaccination requirements.
And this is because some younger kids
are currently ineligible for vaccination
and the vaccine availability for kids
varies across the globe.
But kids between the ages of two and 17
do need to take a pre-departure COVID test
if they're flying,
and that's regardless
of their citizenship.
If they're traveling with
a fully vaccinated adults,
they can present a test that was taken
within three days of departure.
But if they're traveling alone
or with unvaccinated adults,
then they need to present a test
that was taken within
one day of departure.
(gentle music)